I mean the purpose of writing my book
was to express myself to continue being
a storyteller and these are true stories
it's called life in parts because of the
parts we play not only the parts I
played in my profession but also the
parts we play as human beings I'm a
father I'm a husband I'm a brother I'm a
citizen a neighbor and all those things
and we all are we we all present
ourselves now I also wanted to to write
honestly because I thought if I'm not
telling the truth then what's the point
it's masturbatory and which has its
place in in your life but not in this
case I I wanted to present it to say
okay here's what I was afraid here's
when I was insecure this is a times when
it was really trying on me or testing me
the two incidents that you you mentioned
I had a I was married once before to a
lovely young woman who we just we
weren't suited for each other and we so
we separated we parted ways and out of
that for a year together nasai was newly
single and within a month or so I was in
our audition and I met this woman named
Ava was the name I changed and she was
aggressive and assertive and beautiful
and and I was kind of taken aback and
she you know we got together quickly and
we were we were boyfriend and girlfriend
before I could blink and and then I
realized there was something off about
her and what was off about her is that
she was addicted to drugs but I never
knew exactly what kind of drugs
I was very really very ignorant about
drugs because I was on that track to
become a
police officer and I just never indulged
it smoke pot once in a while but it was
never my thing so it just it didn't
appeal to me and I've never done any
other drug than that so I I was very
ignorant on that and but I noticed her
behavior was different go through all
kinds she would sweating one moment and
then she's fine and then she's down and
she's up and it's like there's something
very strange going on and I tried to get
out of the relationship and she was so
powerful she refused the break-up when I
when I decided I was going to break up
with her I thought of the the possible
scenarios she could be angry
she could be pleading she could be agree
with me yeah I think it's best we should
break up she there could be any number
of things and I thought about how I
would react depending on what reaction
she would give the only thing that I
didn't count on is that she said no just
calmly said no we're not right now Emily
I I don't know how to I don't know what
to do with that and she was so
aggressive and assertive that she just
kept pulling me into her life and it was
crazy it's a longer story but that she
started stalking me and showed up at
work I was working on a soap opera at
the time in New York and she showed up
at work and she was thrown out of the
studio and and she would leave these
messages on my answering machine in
those days the early 80s and threatening
me that she was going to have me killed
and when I least expected she said you
know I can I could find you anytime look
like I was on the floor of your show
that's how easy and it really Oh like
she's right and she was very smart and
it was like oh my god at any moment she
can have someone just kill me and she
said specifically that the one Achilles
heel that she had was that she she loved
her mother deeply
and I had met her mother a couple times
and she's a lovely lady and I one time I
picked up the phone I usually didn't
answer the phone I picked up the phone
it was her and I went oh God
and I just told her I said look Ava
don't ever call me again
leave me alone no more threats I have
all these threats on my answering
machine if you continue with this I will
tell your mother I will let your mother
listen to you're threatening my life
silence silence on the phone and she
came back on and said I want that tape I
want that dairenji screaming obscenities
that means and I went hey listen me
isn't me I promise you I will erase
these tapes if you leave me alone but if
you don't I will give me your mother but
if you leave me alone I your mother will
never hear them I promise you that
I'm coming for the tape I'm coming for
the tapes and this was at the point of I
was already shaking because she had made
so many threats against my life
she came over to my apartment I knew she
knew where I lived and she buzzed of
course in New York you buzz every every
apartment someone's going to buzz you
back in you don't really you know it
just happened so she came up and she's
pounding on my door that man she's
screaming I mean I walked I was cast
just a mad woman and I am at the foot of
my bed curled up in a ball and part of
me I think when I think back on it was
embarrassed this young woman I was 28
years old I was a strapping strong young
man this woman was five foot two a
hundred and five and and I'm frightened
of her and there was some III think
there was some embarrassment along with
that if I'm honest and it made me
realize that
it doesn't matter how small someone is
its power it's someone who's taking
power and and using it or abusing it as
the case may be anyway I'm at the I'm at
the foot of my bed curled up into a ball
and I finally had it and I just calmly
got up and I went to the door and I
unlocked the door and I opened the door
she was there I grabbed her by the back
of the hair and I pulled her in closed
the door and I pulled her into my room
and there was one brick wall in my
apartment at the time and I took her by
the back of the head and I slammed her
head into the brick wall over and over
and over again
I just kept slamming her head into the
brick wall until blood and brain matter
was dripping down the brick down to the
floor and then I jotted and realized I
was still at the foot of my bed and I
looked over to the brick wall of course
nothing was there I am panting like a
sick dog and shallow breaths I was so
scared because what I saw in my vision
was so real I saw myself like step out
of my body calmly and kill this woman
who I was frightened of I was like a
cornered animal and I came out and
attacked and that was an experience that
really happened excuse me I used that in
Breaking Bad when when I felt I got so
angry at Mike I could kill him I got I
could kill someone else
why how how is that possible well I had
this experience in my life and I knew
that even the me
justperson among us if pressured if
given the set of circumstances that were
dire could become extremely dangerous
that's where Walter White went he became
extremely dangerous to himself to others
because of a condition that he was in he
felt he was forced into a certain place
that he had to defend himself like Ava
like me in my in my bedroom cowering
frightened out of my mind to the point
where I envisioned this murder and it
made me realize how how desperate human
beings could become and the best thing I
could say out of it is that it I was
able to use it in sort of a therapeutic
way in my in my art to be able to
express myself so I don't harbor these
feelings they I purge them so that's
real
[Music]
you